[Applause]
is that being a vegetarian is taking care of the people
strong fall of the dollar on the counter retreated
badly it was boss road show enjoy everything
until Sunday afternoon went
to bed that's what we do at ufam taxi
to action center is monitoring surveillance
in real time at the external border of the
union the father the shape and the pet
the plane that is currently at the
border the image is discussed said
politi in croatia about 20 minutes
jorge
our main objective is a
cargo ship that has shown
suspicious behavior
when there is an attention this
information is passed in real time to
the member states with which we are
collaborating each and the mixed team in the
monitor liked and surveillance cameras
zav ona and not informed to be born and where it
shows that patrola at the mass on the 13th
what zahar marketing
is that as we are not only dealing with
an external border of the state itself
we are also defending the interests
of the european union as a whole in black
morgan l  ily goes already on the front tea can
support the state in the end the cases the class
in various actions that led to the demand of the
moment when human trafficking networks
is certain to be a success case
we feel a certain about a
very strong feeling of  mission accomplished
warsaw is almost like a second
home
it is probably the thing that i
miss the most about portugal besides the
family it will be the sun lady and even smaller i
just think there is something there just that my
wish for the future will be to be able to
continue working in an environment
multicultural multinational and being able to
continue to contribute to a tougher Europe
[Music]